Trascrizione: Alessio Politi
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Parliamo di innovazione,
e vorrei partire ricordando a tutti
che l'innovazione oggi è,
senza ombra di dubbio,
la principale arma
di cui dispongono le imprese
per competere con successo sul mercato.
E questo è forse ancora più vero
per quelle imprese,
come molte delle aziende italiane,
che non possono contare su altre armi
come la dimensione,
e quindi le efficienze di scala
che ne conseguono,
o l'accesso a fattori produttivi,
come il lavoro o l'energia,
a costi competitivi.
Quindi l'innovazione oggi,
lo sappiamo tutti,
è una priorità in cima all'agenda
di ogni imprenditore e di ogni manager:
tutti ne parlano.
Ma forse non tutti sanno esattamente
cosa sia, nello specifico, l'innovazione.
Io credo che sia molto utile vederla,
e definirla, come un processo:
non è nient'altro che una serie di azioni,
una serie di decisioni,
attraverso cui un'impresa,
un'organizzazione
o noi stessi, un individuo,
generano un'idea
per un nuovo prodotto, un nuovo servizio,
un nuovo modo di fare le cose -
e poi la trasformano in realtà,
la sviluppano, la rendono concreta
e la portano sul mercato.
Tradizionalmente, direi
fino a una ventina di anni fa,
le imprese hanno ritenuto
che per innovare con successo
fosse fondamentale controllare,
avere al proprio interno,
disporre internamente
di tutte le risorse, le competenze,
le tecnologie, le idee
e le conoscenze necessarie
per portare avanti questo processo.
L'idea di fondo era molto semplice:
per innovare di più, dobbiamo
investire di più internamente,
assumere i migliori talenti,
tecnici, designer, ingegneri, scienziati
e aumentare, anno dopo anno,
gli investimenti nei nostri laboratori
di ricerca e sviluppo.
L'idea di fondo
da qualcuno è stata nominata
"closed innovation", l'innovazione chiusa:
il concetto secondo cui per un'impresa,
per innovare con continuità,
e quindi per competere sul mercato,
fosse necessario espandere continuamente
e approfondire continuamente
il proprio know how,
ossia la propria base
di competenze distintive.
Ci sono parecchi studi
che mostrano che questo modo
di fare innovazione nelle organizzazioni
produce una sindrome,
quella che qualcuno ha chiamato
la sindrome del "non inventato qui".
Quante volte di fronte
a un'idea, uno stimolo
che proviene da fuori
i confini di un'organizzazione,
ci siamo sentiti dire : "Be', questa cosa
la sapremmo fare meglio noi".
Ecco, la sindrome del
"non inventato qui" è proprio questo:
la tendenza, spesso anche inconsapevole,
a giudicare come di minor valore,
di minor potenziale,
un'idea, un contributo,
una soluzione che ci viene da fuori.
Qualcuno appunto l'ha chiamata
la sindrome del non inventato qui:
una barriera culturale,
spesso inconsapevole,
che incontriamo nelle organizzazioni.
Questo modo di fare innovazione,
che abbiamo chiamato "innovazione chiusa",
è stato il modello dominante,
fino a circa una ventina di anni fa;
ma possiamo ancora oggi considerarlo
un approccio all'innovazione efficace?
Be', le cose sono profondamente cambiate,
negli ultimi 20 anni.
Innanzitutto, il processo di innovazione
è diventato molto più complesso,
e molto più costoso.
Per rispondere alle esigenze dei clienti,
che cambiano sempre più velocemente;
per far fronte a una competizione
che è sempre più globale,
e sempre più imprevedibile,
oggi le organizzazioni devono innovare
incorporando nei loro prodotti o servizi
molte più tecnologie,
spesso con una natura digitale,
rispetto a quanto accadeva
qualche anno fa.
Prendiamo l'esempio
del mondo dell'automotive:
c'è chi ritiene che da qui a tre anni
la parte principale del valore
che verrà creato
nella filiera dell'automotive
sarà relativa alla componente software,
e non più all'hardware delle autovetture.
E questo impone una
profondissima trasformazione
nel modo di fare innovazione
delle imprese che lavorano
in questo settore.
Volenti o nolenti, e in qualche forma
lo stanno già facendo,
devono diventare capaci di sviluppare,
o quantomeno integrare,
software e sistemi informatici
di varia natura.
Ed è molto difficile, come capirete,
farlo, facendo leva, confidando
solo sulle proprie competenze,
risorse e tecnologie.
C'è un secondo fenomeno molto rilevante,
ossia il fatto che oggi il ciclo di vita
di un nuovo prodotto, di un nuovo servizio
dopo che è stato portato sul mercato
si è accorciato sensibilmente.
Ricordo le parole
dell'amministratore delegato
di Hewlett-Packard,
che qualche anno fa diceva:
"Oggi, i nostri prodotti
restano sul mercato tra sei e 12 mesi.
Cinque anni prima,
stavano sul mercato
tra i tre e i cinque anni".
E questo fenomeno di accelerazione
del ciclo di innovazione
è un qualcosa che è comune
a tantissimi settori industriali.
Lo vediamo anche noi,
quando andiamo a comprare
un elettrodomestico a Media World,
per fare un esempio.
Quindi, oggi,
non solo innovare è più complesso,
ma bisogna farlo anche molto,
molto più velocemente.
E quindi, cosa stanno facendo oggi
le imprese più innovative?
Che risposta stanno dando a questa sfida?
Stanno investendo di più internamente,
nei loro laboratori e processi
di ricerca e sviluppo e innovazione?
In realtà non è proprio così:
prendete l'esempio di Apple.
L'anno scorso, Apple ha investito
il 5,4 percento del suo fatturato
in ricerca e sviluppo.
Un dato molto lontano
da quello di altre imprese,
come Microsoft o Google,
che hanno investito il 13, il 14,
il 15 percento del loro fatturato
in ricerca e innovazione.
E questa è una costante
della storia di Apple
degli ultimi cinque-sei anni,
e non possiamo certo dire
che non sia stata,
e non continui ad essere
un'impresa molto, molto innovativa.
Quello che le imprese
che oggi sanno innovare veramente
hanno dimostrato di fare,
e hanno imparato a fare,
è quello di far evolvere il loro modello,
il loro approccio all'innovazione
da una logica chiusa a una logica aperta.
Oggi, il modello
che queste imprese adottano
si chiama "open innovation".
E che differenza c'è tra il modello chiuso
e il modello aperto di innovazione?
L'idea è molto semplice:
si basa sul riconoscere
che oggi non è più sufficiente
disporre al proprio interno,
continuare ad investire
sulle proprie tecnologie,
sul proprio know how.
È forse più veloce, più efficace,
meno costoso, meno rischioso,
saper identificare, cercare, utilizzare
le idee, le competenze,
le tecnologie e il know how
che già esistono fuori dai confini
della nostra organizzazione.
L'idea è molto affascinante:
poi bisogna, però, metterla in pratica.
Ed esistono oggi tantissimi
strumenti molto concreti
con cui si può dar corpo
a questo principio.
Alcuni sono anche molto noti
e utilizzati da tempo:
prendiamo ad esempio il caso di Alessi,
che tutti conosciamo,
l'impresa che produce
accessori per la casa.
Nel corso degli anni '90,
ha visto crescere il suo fatturato
da 20 a 100 milioni di euro
rivoluzionando il suo modello
di innovazione.
Alessi ha cominciato
a lavorare sistematicamente
con un network di oltre
200 designer e architetti
che stavano fuori da Alessi
che l'hanno aiutata a reinterpretare
il significato dei prodotti
che l'impresa sviluppava
e portava sul mercato,
intercettando e interpretando
dei cambiamenti culturali
che in quegli anni si stavano verificando
nella nostra società.
Potete facilmente immaginare
quanto fosse più ampio il contributo
di creatività e di conoscenza
che questa rete
di architetti e di designer
è riuscita a mettere
a disposizione dell'impresa,
se confrontato con quello
che avrebbero potuto fare
i designer direttamente assunti
da Alessi stessa.
Un secondo strumento è quello che consiste
nel dar vita a delle collaborazioni
con Università, centri di ricerca
o imprese che lavorano in settori
completamente diversi dal nostro
per dar vita a dei progetti di sviluppo
di ampio respiro e di lunga durata.
Un esempio in questo senso
è Dompé Farmaceutici
che poco tempo fa ha creato,
nel suo laboratorio di ricerca e sviluppo,
in cui investe il 15 percento
del suo fatturato ogni anno,
un dipartimento che si chiama
proprio "open innovation".
E cosa fa?
Ha il compito di sviluppare, misurare,
far crescere e utilizzare
una rete di relazioni
con oltre 200 università
e centri di ricerca in giro per il mondo
con cui Dompé innova quotidianamente.
E la stessa cosa che,
ad esempio, fa anche Cosberg,
la nota impresa italiana
nel settore dell'automazione
che collabora con decine
di università e centri di ricerca,
in Europa ma non solo.
Cosberg però fa qualcosa oltre:
è partner di Intellimech,
che è uno dei più grandi consorzi
di ricerca precompetitiva
nel campo della meccatronica, al mondo,
che mette insieme, fa lavorare insieme
oltre 30 imprese,
centri di ricerca e università,
che si scambiano continuamente
idee, soluzioni e tecnologie
per accelerare e migliorare
la capacità di innovare
di ciascuno dei partner
di questo consorzio.
Pensate che, negli ultimi anni,
Cosberg ha messo a punto
16 brevetti innovativi
nel campo dell'automazione
sfruttando le competenze e gli stimoli
che provenivano da questo consorzio.
Ci sono però oggi molti altri strumenti,
anche più innovativi,
che le imprese hanno cominciato
ad utilizzare solo più recentemente,
per fare open innovation.
Ad esempio, è in netta crescita
il numero di imprese
che collaborano sistematicamente,
e spesso anche investono nel capitale,
di startup o piccole imprese
molto innovative.
Nel far questo, aiutate anche
dal ruolo di ponte, di collegamento,
svolto dagli incubatori
o dagli acceleratori di imprese
come ad esempio PoliHub,
che è l'incubatore di startup
del Politecnico di Milano,
che ospita più di 130 startup innovative.
Ci sono poi, oggi, anche
piattaforme online.
Non so se avete mai sentito parlare
di Innocentive, o di Nine Sigma,
che aiutano le imprese
che vogliono innovare
a entrare in contatto con comunità
di tecnici, ingegneri,
docenti universitari.
In alcuni casi, si tratta
di centinaia di migliaia, se non milioni,
di quelli che vengono chiamati solver,
che aiutano le imprese
che desiderano innovare
a trovare soluzioni innovative
ai problemi tecnici più complessi
che si trovano ad affrontare.
Un altro strumento che negli ultimi anni
è sempre più utilizzato
sono i contest d'innovazione
e gli hackaton.
Sono degli strumenti
attraverso cui le imprese
possono coinvolgere fornitori, clienti,
partner, studenti, docenti
nel generare nuovi concept
per prodotti, servizi
che poi vanno a portare sul mercato.
Un esempio interessante, in questo senso,
è la "Global Packaging Challenge"
lanciata nel 2019 da Amadori,
la nota impresa
nel settore agroalimentare,
che ha coinvolto una serie di fornitori
attuali e futuri dell'impresa stessa
nel mettere a punto
delle soluzioni sostenibili
per i sistemi di imballaggio
di Amadori stessa,
ed è stato un progetto
di grandissimo successo.
Il messaggio che volevo trasmettervi
è che oggi ci sono tantissimi strumenti,
tantissimi tool che si possono usare
per concretizzare l'idea
dell'innovazione aperta.
E non sono degli strumenti
a disposizione solo delle grandi imprese
e delle multinazionali.
Anzi, forse utilizzare
e sfruttare questi strumenti
è ancora più importante,
diventa ancora più prioritario
per le piccole imprese,
come molte di quelle che ci sono
in Italia e nel nostro territorio.
Chiaramente, per far questo
bisogna prendere consapevolezza
di un cambio di paradigma importante.
Noi abbiamo sempre creduto
che fosse fondamentale,
per innovare con successo,
disporre di un solido know how,
un set di competenze
e di tecnologie distintive
che l'impresa presidiava, su cui investiva
e che faceva crescere nel tempo.
Oggi le imprese che abbiamo visto,
e tutte le altre che hanno intrapreso
una strada verso l'open innovation,
hanno capito che il know how
non è più sufficiente.
E hanno cominciato a sviluppare
quello che io chiamo il "know-where",
cioè l'interconnessione
con il mondo esterno
e la capacità di trovare
velocemente e efficacemente,
prima dei miei competitor,
dove stanno le idee,
le soluzioni e le tecnologie
che servono per accelerare
e rendere più efficace
il mio processo di innovazione.
Chiaramente, per far questo
bisogna superare quella barriera culturale
di cui abbiamo parlato,
la "sindrome del non inventato qui".
È fondamentale che le imprese capiscano,
da un lato il valore intrinseco
delle idee e delle soluzioni
che provengono da fuori
dei suoi laboratori di ricerca e sviluppo;
e in secondo luogo, è fondamentale
che conoscano quegli strumenti,
sappiano in cosa consistono
e sappiano come si mettono
concretamente in pratica.
Ecco, io credo che oggi
questa è la sfida principale
per ogni impresa:
saper "mettere a terra"
il concetto di open innovation
e fare evolvere la propria filosofia
e il proprio approccio all'innovazione
da un modello chiuso,
direi autoreferenziale,
verso questo modello
espansivo e interconnesso
che abbiamo chiamato innovazione aperta.
(Applausi)